[Music]
all right what's up reject nation what's
shakin it's your man Greg Alva here and
I'm just kidding it's John kids you
couldn't tell
listen we just got back from seeing
transformers last night and I thought
what better way to get my head in the
game ready to talk about Optimus Prime
and this new pitch perfect 3 trailer I'm
gonna miss you right now I haven't seen
the second one but I did see the first
one and I like the person a lot I had a
good time pitch perfect 3 when I'm going
in fresh so let's let's see how this
goes let's cue this trail up here the
Barden Bellas an unlikely group of not
men who somehow managed to win it
something that didn't have to do with
baking I can't hear you slider 5 manatee
life with a set of white Bridget oh
we're not becoming pretenders we all
expected feel really good about Lerner
right now and trying to get into bed
school fingers come where are they now
my name is about anyone house so let's
get practice I could my job so fun no I
quit I would do anything with being with
you guys again
Eddie you guys every year the US episode
is performance for the strip in red
to get us an invite yeah suddenly got a
bunch of free time so with the plan I
just sing other people's songs like
Harry okay Harry oh so cute climbing
astronomy Russell and charity I joined
yogurt I could be another day on stage
for the Bellas
this is they're all designed for their
very unreliable effects one of the
hallmarks of your personality you're not
remembering all the times I've been also
[Music]
[Music]
try to muscle dignity
[Music]
yeah well we're not doing anything with
dignity
[Music]
they really do need the gym to work for
you yeah okay okay um so I I guess from
what I'm getting from this trailer this
is jump right and what I'm getting from
this trailer is it's the last hurrah
maybe if it if it unless it makes a ton
of money as you some of you might recall
Elizabeth Banks jumped out of the acting
Stephen Ames the director's chair for
part two and that is not the case this
time around no Trish see sighs something
is directing this one this time step up
all in she did before this like I said I
saw the first one and I had a good time
you know it was a pretty fun comedy
mixed with you know different dynamic
with the musical element the acapella a
world I am not as familiar with and uh
this while this doesn't look like fun in
some ways I feel like I just can't tell
what kind of movie they want to make
this any more like if they want this to
be like big crazy you got explosions
that they're running away from and like
aircraft stuff the first impression I
get off this trailer is I'm having a
little trouble figuring out what
direction they're heading what kind of
comedy they're trying to make with this
because I mean towards the end there
you've got them running away from an
explosion like jumping off a ship and
and you know Anna Kendrick getting
sucked out of an aircraft like the mummy
or some [ __ ] I'm a little confused I
guess conflicted by the the tone they're
trying to set here I mean I like the
ensemble of these movies I didn't see
Part C like I said so I haven't seen
like Hailee Steinfeld in the mix but
generally speaking I like the ensemble I
think the singing is good and you know I
like these kinds of comedies you know I
like this to show I like bring it on
some of these like you know competition
based comedies not they're exactly the
same as this I feel like once you get a
few sequels deep I like the fact that
they're going with the whole meta kind
of things these ladies really need to
join the workforces like you know do
something real after so many
competitions
how soon is it until you just get onto
DVD like bring it on like there are only
so many of the same competition you can
go for after so long but I don't know I
mean this is a cool twist going for the
USO makes sense and I like to see you
know I always enjoy seeing John Michael
Higgins and and it was the banks you
know doing their their funny banter
thing kind of like Fred Willard and the
British guy who name I can't remember
from best-in-show like I like I like all
the elements but yeah you know stuff
they're adding to this except they're
they're trying to do to make it look
fresh III really don't know about you
know I can't tell if they want to do
gross that like amp up the gross out amp
up the action you know I think it's
again cool that they're adding in like
ah you got this other this other rival
band now that the real band with their
own songs and real instruments and at
least for the sake of the movie that
leaves me going wire how are they gonna
pull this one out or why are they in the
same competition Ruby Rose is in
everything right now I mean I'm
interested to see her in a movie like
this one this doesn't look like a
surefire hit to me I mean I'm sure that
there's something about a movie like
this there's always a fun return value
if you just like those characters and I
do like watching them a lot of the time
I think Anna Kendrick is a good kind of
punchy spunky lead you know I like her
interplay with Brittany Snow a rebel
Wilson man I like rebel Wilson I think
she's funny three movies deep I'm like
fat fat Amy jokes just keep on rolling
that fat Amy train and I don't know how
to at this point I don't know how I feel
about that like how many fat jokes we
can do there's gotta be something I've
always wished for rebel Wilson that
people would write more than his fat
jokes for her but hey I mean she still
makes me laugh with them so I guess that
to something yeah I don't know this
honestly this trailer looks a little
long in the tooth for me I like this
site I like the idea of pitch perfect I
feel goodwill towards it but just as a
trailer I don't know how
movies terminal you know that's the same
writer as the first two movies so I
guess that bodes well
but um yeah I'm feeling kind of Luke on
this trailer and you know it's gonna I
think it's going to come down to the
word of metal for me oh yeah
piss perfect 3 trailer boys and girls
are you excited comment below let me
know alright thank you guys for joining
me on this sequel to my into the storm
reaction you can subscribe to the real
rejects by hitting that subscribe button
that's wet to subscribe on it also click
that notification bell to get notified
every time one of our new videos is out
if you're fan going to want to do that
my name is John Humphrey I live here on
this channel co-created it with the G
train he's just outside in the balcony I
can see him from here I'm also go check
out bloom house calm you're in a horror
I also work for that but it's weird to
plug yourself to feel strange in my body
okay and we got a call bunch of cool
stuff happening on patreon right now if
you want to come check out our patreon
community we actually found a video just
recently that we're going to be putting
up there that everybody can see so keep
a lookout for that join us next time
o capella stuff Oh Ella I mean it's not
it's not as cool winds it's just here
all right guys so pinch perfect three
first impressions right off the bat I've
been saying for a long time that this
franchise really needs to ramp up the
action really needs to ramp up the
espionage I think it should be a
military story and I'm glad that they're
going that direction this time around
finally you know uh connecting with what
I feel like the audience really wants
you know